patrick malvaes il est président du
syndicat national des discothèques
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france
alors tout d'abord quelles sont vos
revendications très du gouvernement à la
revendication la plus urgente de ces
deux mètres ce secteur en apnée en
respiration artificielle parce que
maintenant plus de trois mois de
fermeture une perspective de sept mois
de fermeture et peut-être beaucoup plus
s'il ya une deuxième fois que vous avez
vous qui est fort justement il faut
absolument des mesures d'urgence
financière puisque ces secteurs ne peut
plus fonctionner ces exploitants comme
son personnel sont à l'agonie et si on
veut que ce secteur continue de vivre et
que 8000 personnes seront pas au chômage
demain il faut encore que dans celle de
suite alors un secteur exemple
concrètement cela se traduit comment au
moment où on se passe au moment où on se
parle il ya déjà 70 entreprises et qui
son dépôt de bilan il y en a près de 300
hommes qui vont suivre
ça c'est de suite qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que les exploitants
les 1600 patrons de discothèques et de
loisirs n'ont plus de revenus du tout
c'était non pas à trouver du personnel
de leur personnel est en chômage partiel
de maintenant depuis quatre mois et sans
perspective de l'ouverture ils vont
passer de chômage partiel à chômage
total
ça veut dire que les propriétaires qui
ne touchent plus leurs loyers vont
bientôt mettre en oeuvre la clause
résolutoire qui permet d'expulser les
exploitants peuvent plus payer des
loyers site absolument normale pour se
mettre aussi la cause des propriétaires
voilà ce que ça veut dire
donc c'était quelque chose qui va
disparaître et les exploitants non
seulement ils ont perdu leurs revenus
mensuels mais y perdent aussi leur bien
leur entreprise puisque c'est un fonds
de commerce est content comme ça plus
rien valoir
or pour monter un fonds de commerce une
opération patrimoniale pour monter une
discothèque
c'est à dire que vous avez emprunté à la
famille aux proches et pour le système
bancaire qui veut pas prêter
donc vous avez gagné votre maison vos
biens etc ils vont perdre tous leurs
biens alors les représentants de
du secteur demandent un plan de relance
au que demandez vous concrètement à
concrètement il faut que de suite le
chômage partiel soit reconduit à 100%
il faut que les frais fixes il ya
pratiquement 200 250 millions d'euros de
prêt fixe pour tous les établissements
de nuit
on a enfin de faire leur colvin et en
carriole pour ce soir j'ai dit qu'il de
trois personnes qui sont pas taris que
là dessus pour actualiser les données
mais c'est à peu près 250 millions qu'il
faudrait injecter pour payer ce qu'on
appelle les préfixes c'est à dire les
loyers c'est à dire l'eau le gaz et
l'électricité les des empreintes
dentaires de tout ce qui fait dire une
entreprise
donc on est en train de quantifier tout
ça mais je retombe tout à fait sur les
pas de ce que nous avions dit mais la
fille non parce que le ministre alain
grise et nous a demandé quelque chose de
très précis et ce sera très précis dès
demain dès demain il y aura ces données
pour lui et sur la date d'une éventuelle
réouverture
est-ce que vous avez des tice alors aux
informations notre position est tout à
fait clair il y a un impératif sanitaire
nationale il n'est pas question pour les
discothèques d'échapper à la nationale
de santé elles sont prêtes à vraiment à
ouvrir à cet impératif national etc
doivent rester fermés jusqu'en janvier
seront fermés choix janvier est par
contre il faut qu'elles soient pris
entièrement en charge et il faut que
l'on ne tolère pas que d'autres puissent
faire discothèque alors qu elles elles
peuvent pas le faire que ce à quoi on
assiste actuellement pointe discothèque
c'est très facile au jour d'aujourd'hui
il suffit de n'être pas une discothèque
et au ventre il sautait vous le voyez
dans les rues vous voyez dans les bars
envoyés dans les maisons vous voyez là
les locations et abriel be partout sur
les discothèques et le risque est accru
demain il va y avoir une deuxième vague
qui sera due à ces débordements clan ne
contient pas que l'on ne combat pas et
cette deuxième vague des quelles vont
être les premiers sanctionnés
ça va être les patrons de discothèques
parce que eux n'y sont pour rien
puisqu'ils seront fermés et eux vont pas
pouvoir les ouvrir au mois de septembre
donc c'est trouver pire est encore
différé ça va être une double peine de
l'envoi donc moi personnellement je ne
tiens pas de plan sur la comète soldats
d'ouverture on part comme si on devrait
on devait réouvrir au mois de septembre
mais vu ce dont on peut constater vu le
laxisme gouvernement ne pas généraliser
et d'ailleurs on en demandait un réseau
injustice également on n'hésitera pas vu
tout ça c'est peu probable
c'est peu probable et on assistera ce
que l'on voit aujourd'hui du binge
drinking les forces de police débordée
par les jeunes qui font n'importe quoi
et organise importe quoi on l'a vu dans
la nièvre on le voit partout toujours
les incivilités et moi la mairie de
bordeaux qui est ma région se plaint de
ce que l'on peut voir comme incivilités
à bordeaux et les femmes aux visées de
s'organiser pour rentrer chez elles en
toute sécurité
mais ça va ça évidemment si vous avez
aucune structure qui est prêt à
accueillir tous les jeunes et qui est
prêt à les contenir
ça va avoir lieu dans les rues un peu
partout donc ouvert que les visiteurs
n'ont souhaité les lions à la rentrée
mais elle aura lieu que s'ils ont mis
fin au bazar organisé que l'on n'ait se
dérouler
merci à vous patrick malvaes je rappelle
que le président du syndicat national
des discothèques